font plutôt rassurant c'est le premier
résultat parce qu'on voit qu'on a quand
même un bloc de gauche qui dégage une
majorité par rapport au reste des
candidatures même si ça reste serré
évidemment une inquiétude vis-à-vis
d'abstention qui continue d'être
importante et là on a toujours un gros
travail à mener pour restaurer le
dialogue avec avec les citoyens
maintenant voilà il ya un gros chantier
qui s'appelle travailler à l'union de la
gauche
on s'y attelle dès à présent avant avec
une équipe de négociation qui retrouve
le parti socialiste d'ici quelques
minutes et on va on va essayer d'être
voilà dans dans l'idée d'union une au
fort de la gauche avec un certain nombre
de points de négociation qui nous
permettons nous de valoriser des idées
de l'écologie dans cette candidature de
bauchi